hello freak [ __ ] for people that
don't know what's going on let's lay out
all of all the events that have
transpired essentially you were being
asked to step away from your college for
a day is that what it was is it one day
well this goes back farther yeah there
is let's lay out the whole thing okay so
we couldn't possibly lay out the whole
thing but it's just for people that have
no idea what's going on
right they're listening right now and
they're like who's this Brett Weinstein
guy so the core of it surrounds a
tradition that we have at Evergreen
called day of absence and this tradition
stretches back long before I was ever at
the college I've been there 15 years
this tradition stretches back into I
think the early 70s and it's it's built
around a play written by Douglas Turner
Ward a black play right and the play
portrays events in a fictional town
where the black population decides not
to show up one day in order to emphasize
their their roles in the town that the
white population is unaware of and as
you would imagine all hell breaks loose
so anyway that's an excellent play and
some early faculty at our college
decided that we should have a day that
mirrored this event and originally black
faculty and students and then later
people of color would leave campus for a
day to emphasize the role that they play
in our community and then they would
later the the tradition was amended and
add a day of presence added to it where
people would come back to campus and
this has been going on as I said since
the 70s and the whole time I've been
there and then this year it was
announced by the organizing committee
that the the situation would be reversed
and they asked white student staff and
faculty not to come to campus and that
did not at all sit well with me as I
said in my letter to the the person who
had announced this Rashida though I
should say his staff and I she has ended
up at the center of this controversy I
think wrongly just because my letter in
response is addressed to her and then it
was
made public by our school paper so her
name has been dragged front and center
but in any case my letter I said that
there was all the difference in the
world between a population deciding to
absent themselves from a shared space in
order to highlight their role and a
population deciding to absent another
population from a shared space which I
find unacceptable as as a person as
somebody devoted to the gains of the
civil rights movement I just I and I
should also probably say as a Jew and
when people start telling me where I can
and cannot be it it rings alarm bells so
that's the gist of the story and the
letter caused quite a stir amongst
student staff and faculty who responded
many of them quite angrily privately of
course people were much more divided on
the matter and there were plenty of
people who agreed with my letter but
publicly speaking there was condemnation
of the letter but the the event itself
day of absence was mostly uneventful I
did go to campus as I said I would in my
letter and I actually it's neither here
nor there was accidental but while I was
on campus I ran into a student that I
know very well actually student that my
wife and I were abroad in Ecuador with
last year we were teaching abroad and we
had 30 students with us and so one of
the students who had travelled with us
to Ecuador happened to be on campus too
this is a student of color I want to
stop this
sorry that's all right that was going to
go on I was going to drive me crazy
right I was Dan keep going so I ran into
the student that I know well and care
about quite a bit and we had a very nice
conversation mostly not about Dave
absence as a matter of fact I can't even
remember if we did talk about Dave
absence but there was something poignant
to me about the fact that while I was
being condemned for refusing to accept
this new formulation that I was able to
meet with a student who is important to
me and the neither of our racial
backgrounds is fund is primary in our
relationship we know each other as
people and that's really how I would
like to see all of us interacting on
campus we all have our backgrounds they
matter to us but it can it cannot become
the primary interface between us let me
stop you here and let me try to
understand what the reaction was because
you rightly said that you think there's
a huge problem with asking people to not
show up simply based on their color of
their skin exactly and what was the
argument against that like when when you
said that and I read your letter and
your letter didn't sound racist at all
it sounded very well thought out it made
a very good point but the response the
inflammatory response to your letter was
so disturbing and shocking was there
anyone who had reasonable debate with
you about this was there anyone who said
well we we should take into
consideration why they're asking us to
do this we should sit down with them we
should talk through this was there was
there anything reasonable or was it just
dig your heels in the sand and then let
the insults and the white privilege and
all these accusations fly well like I
said there's a huge difference that you
can't see unless you're at the center of
one of these things between the public
discussion and the private discussion
privately I had very interesting
discussions with many people that was
not apps
but if you were to look in on the
discussion at the public level it looked
as if there was consensus united against
me now when you say public and private
are the same people making contradictory
statements in public that are that are
commiserating with you in private or is
it just different people a few of them
do that the act that actually is the
thing I find most surprising is that
sometimes people will privately say one
thing to you and then publicly do
another mostly it's different people and
I should say the people who have talked
to me privately and expressed concerns
are actually a quite a diverse group so
it's not as if white folks are disturbed
by this and people of color are united
it's not at all like that but the part
of the hidden story here is that in
order to invent advance certain policy
proposals it has to appear that the
community is united behind them and that
anybody who stands against them is
standing against them for illegitimate
reasons so that means that the number of
people who are willing to express any
sort of nuance about what's taking place
has to be small and they have to be
dismissible so what they did is they
called me a racist which is ironic
because I'm an anti-racist I really have
gone out of my way to first of all study
the question of why racism occurs and I
I believe been pretty courageous in
fighting against it where I've run into
it so to challenge me with that
particular epithet was a mistake on
their part it was a strategic mistake
and I kept trying to tell them while
this was still internally being
discussed in the college I kept trying
to tell them that they should really
check the concept that I'm a racist they
should ask because if they did they
would discover that they were actually
way off the mark and then they would
have an interesting puzzle on their
hands then they would have to explain to
themselves why they had found themselves
hurling this most poisonous term at
somebody who not only isn't a racist but
is pretty nearly the opposite well it's
it's a standard maneuver when someone
wants to silence someone when someone
wants to put someone in a category
that's instantly recognizable one
best ones is racist oh absolutely and
and what I found is that people simply
could not figure out what they would do
if that term was applied to them right
they were able to preview in their minds
what that would be like and so many
people could see that there was no
escape for them right so they like being
called a rapist almost it's like even if
you are exonerated there's still that
cloud hanging hanging above you yes but
this also actually points to something
pretty important for anybody who travels
this ground themself they're going to
discover this that many of the terms
that are being used have been redefined
but they haven't been fully redefined so
one of the things that I've seen in
several places is that a term like
racist has been redefined so that the
bar for being a racist is so low that
you couldn't possibly help but rip over
it but then once you've tripped over it
and you have accepted that you are a
racist
then the stigma goes back to the
original definition so it is the dodging
and weaving between the two definitions
that actually does the heavy lifting
well there's also a really disturbing
idea that's being bounced around lately
that it's impossible to be racist if
you're anything other than white right
and it's ridiculous it's preposterous
anybody who looks at the actual
definition of racism will discover that
that's preposterous
but yes that does pass in certain places
as logical yeah and just it's parroted
in this very bizarre way that's supposed
to be unchallenged and this is a fairly
recent thing I mean this is not
something that existed two decades ago
right I agree and the pace at which it's
moving in the last few years is very
surprising it is surprising but it kind
of makes sense because you get into
these route groups of people they have
this confirmation bias they lump up
together and they all reinforce their
ideas in this echo chamber and they all
do it inside the colleges and then when
it gets out to the rest of the world as
we're seeing with your case at Evergreen
the rest of worlds like what is going on
over here like what is happening in
school and people who are sending their
children off to school are very
concerned with the indoctrination of
these I
and adopting these very rigid mindsets
that the rest of the world just simply
could pick apart pretty quickly
well this is the most shocking thing
because I'm you know I'm I haven't been
censured I haven't been suspended I'm
still on the email distribution list so
I'm watching the traffic inside of my
college and I'm able to compare it to
the huge flood of stuff that I'm seeing
from the outside world as they get wind
of what's going on at Evergreen and the
difference is a million miles inside of
Evergreen actually we are descending
further into madness the the faculty are
blaming the fact that the campus had to
be suddenly closed due to a threat from
the outside yesterday on me for having
talked about this in the outside world
specifically for larious I cannot I
can't use that term yet hopefully
someday because I I hope it's soon and
you know I must say one thing that I
don't know we haven't even talked about
where this where I got thrust into the
spotlight here which your listeners are
going to have to know in order to
understand why I'm even sitting here but
but the the intensity and the out of
touch nature of the discussion inside
the college simply reinforces the the
impression that something is desperately
off that that what we really have is a
filter bubble that is so so strong that
even when the world sends very clear
evidence that you've missed something
somewhere and it's time to rethink what
you've been doing they're not waking up
and I love this college this college we
maybe we'll get to talk about it but the
structuring of this college is so
unusual and what one can do as a
professor at Evergreen if you're really
dedicated to teaching it is the place to
be because you have unparalleled
pedagogical freedom more freedom than
you'd have as a tenured professor at
Harvard and you also have room to teach
individually to students because our
students take one program at a time
there
full-time in one program and the
professors teach one program at a time
full-time and they can go on for a full
year so imagine you've got 25 students
and you have them for a year full-time
you really know every student in your
class individually not just by name but
you know how they think you know their
backgrounds you know their blind spots
and that allows for a kind of teaching
that can't be done anywhere else so I am
quite distressed at the fact that
Evergreen is now endangered by what's
going on and I really would like to see
it wake up and rescue itself because it
is worth rescuing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]